hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to talk about noticing
and many of you have heard me say that
the three key
elements in language learning are
number one your the attitude of the
learner are you motivated do you like
the language do you have confidence that
you're going to succeed
uh
you know are you resisting the language
or just letting it come in all of these
attitudinal things are the most
important the second thing is how much
time you are prepared to spend with the
language with the language that doesn't
mean necessarily in a classroom it means
with the language listening to it
reading
speaking time with the language and the
third thing is learning to notice but i
think the more people have trouble
understanding that third principle so i
want to discuss a little bit with
reference to my recent effort to improve
in portuguese remember that i said i
would try to improve my portuguese
because i want to make a video on
portuguese and portuguese is not one of
my stronger languages it's down near the
you know bottom there a language that i
have
kind of
you know spent time learning over the
last four or five years
more or less relying on my spanish
pronouncing it more or less like spanish
and so i decided i would try to step it
up a notch
and so what did i do
well one of the first things i did
was that i found well what have i bought
over the years because i have always
bought lots of language learning
material
so
pimsleur is one i have pimpster by the
way for
uh
portuguese and russian
i have a number of these things i have
asimil for russian and korean i have
lots so when i comment on them i comment
from some experience
i've always been not a great fan of
pimpster because it has so little
vocabulary in it
uh that it would take forever to learn a
language to me
um in language learning i want to have a
big vocabulary so that i can understand
people so that i can understand what
i'll read
and so that i can then continue to
increase my vocabulary because the more
you know the more you can learn however
the one good thing about pimpster
is that the sound quality of the
recordings is excellent you have to put
up with the english that's on the the
cds but the portuguese the target
language sound quality is excellent and
they've
the words repeat so that you can really
start to notice how things are
pronounced so that uh in brazilian
portuguese it's not komo it's komu
that that o is in fact an u it's not o
hotel it's u hotel
uh it's not uh you know
do brazil it's do brazil so these kinds
of things that you sometimes don't
notice or you do know they're there but
you don't pay much attention you hear
them on pimster then when i go back into
listening to other more interesting
stuff i find myself noticing some of
those aspects of pronunciation more so
it helps me to notice
similarly
i'm not going to reach for it here but i
have my teacher self portuguese i went
through that very quickly the first time
i looked at that five years ago or so it
made some impression on me but i have
listened to a lot of portuguese since
then so that now
those descriptions of grammar
in that book now refer to something that
i'm familiar with so in fact
it does again quote help me to notice
because i see it there i haven't really
absorbed it but it makes me a little
more sensitive to it so that when i'm
listening and reading i say oh yeah
right that's that aspect that's the what
they call a personal infinitive or
something so i might underline it if i'm
reading or i might pay attention while
i'm listening uh along those lines uh
verbs are a problem
for a learner in portuguese
and so there is a very nice site that i
have now on my ipad
uh here it's called conjugate conjugates
and conjugate conjugate
and there you punch in any verb
and you have the full um con you know
conjugation of all the different tenses
and anything that's irregular
is in orange and they also help you a
little bit for example for the future
subjunctive
cuando e es que ser or cuando tu es que
seres
so that they they help you with it so
in all i just think it's an it's an
excellent tool here again i find i can't
remember from studying these lists but
it does help me to notice so i start to
notice a little more when i'm listening
you know how the ar verbs er verbs ir
verbs uh perform in different tenses so
all of these things help me to notice
however
you know these are like as obviously
that's like the 20 activity the 80
activity is just the massive reading and
listening and armed with this um you
know having become a little more alert
because of looking at the nuts and bolts
then i become a little more attentive
when i'm listening and reading
my main activity has been massive
listening and reading
and today i worked all day in the garden
actually i'm quite exhausted
and so i had on i had my
i had my uh nano here
and i had these wonderful
uh wireless
uh head headphones so i didn't cut
anything and didn't get entangled in the
bushes or anything while i was listening
although i was sweating profusely
and i was listening to
uh
the kite runner in portuguese again some
years ago when i got interested in
portuguese i sent away for some audio
books from brazil and this is one of the
ones that i got it's it's okay
i the other day i was listening in my
car to uh arte de guerra which uh
so i mean my wife now has gone to
toronto to visit with her family so
i'm doing a lot of work around the house
cleaning things up and that sort of
thing i played a couple of games of golf
with friends so
unfortunately my friends don't
appreciate it if i listen while we're
playing golf but it's a 40-minute drive
there 40-minute drive back i'm listening
uh
so
there was oh another one of my favorites
many years ago when i was four or five
years ago it was uh ruben alves who was
a brazilian
educator so i listened a bit of him
and and this i didn't like so much it
was an audio book that i ordered from
brazil but i listened to a bit of it
but the point is oh and my reading
i don't have it all here i found some of
the portuguese books that i bought in
the past this is
unfortunately both these books are
translations these are books because
when i was in portugal i like to buy
books on subjects that interest me i'm
not normally a big reader of fiction
although i have a book by paulo cuello
and i must admit that i just don't like
his stuff very much
uh
so i read this book about the brain and
how the brain learns and stuff even
though it's a translation from english
so i read a bit of that to get myself
going and i also had because i'm
interested in russia and the soviet
union here's a book by martin amos on
stalin again in translation into
portuguese so it really doesn't matter
what you read
if you're exposing yourself to it all
the time i'm trying to notice
and and when i'm listening or when i'm
reading if i see
things that i know what that i have
trouble with like the subjunctive
subjunctive like verbs like which form
of the past tends to use when all these
kinds of things
that i will occasionally consult with my
uh
you know teach yourself or look up my
table on my ipad
then when i'm listening and reading
i want to be paying attention and what
happens is that as i've said before it's
it's like a jigsaw puzzle as more of the
pieces fall into place you're able to
notice more and more things
uh it's not because you saw an
explanation or saw a declension table
that you're going to remember it but as
you are now let's say very comfortable
with a certain case
or you know where not case but a certain
tense or certain vocabulary items then
other things that were just lost in all
the stuff you couldn't really understand
or
whatever make sense of
now those things start to stand out and
you start to notice them so that the
discovery of a language
is all about helping yourself notice
more and more things you whether it be
noticing how things are not pronounced
whether it be noticing
how words are used
uh you know one thing i started to
notice is
uh um
i think it's a crescent era crescent i
don't remember which but it doesn't
really mean to increase it means to add
like someone adds that in a conversation
so i hear in my
audiobook uh karashento or akreshante i
can't remember how much it is
uh
but akrashentar whatever
means to add doesn't mean to increase
our mentor is to increase so you start
to notice things with regard to
vocabulary and how it's used
um
what was another one that i started
noticing uh
about the usage because
it doesn't matter but you start to
notice things in vocabulary you start to
notice things in terms of
grammar now many of these things are
fleeting it's not because you notice it
once that you're able to use it but the
more you notice it the more you
kind of trigger a slight aha
i believe
the more you are forging sort of neural
networks that are going to enable you to
come up with it correctly when you're
speaking
so basically uh
to talk a little bit about how i'm
refreshing my portuguese and how i go
about trying to improve my ability to
notice what's happening in portuguese
in the hope that as i noticed more and
more things and maybe notice and forget
and notice again
and as you can see i couldn't remember
certain things it doesn't matter i never
worry about what i can't remember
because i know that as i go over it
again and go over it again and notice it
here and notice it there eventually it
is going to stick
and so by
maybe making that special deliberate
effort to notice
uh you're going to make things stick a
little faster but ultimately i want to
end on this note ultimately it's that
massive input that's going to do it uh
it's not uh deliberately trying to study
every form of the verb and sitting there
and and i don't like i've never like
write it out long hand 10 times it's not
that in-depth
uh study in my opinion it's more the
sort of it's quali it's quantity over
quality because not only are you then
exposing yourself to that particular
verb ending in different situations but
as you're listening to it you're also
reviewing all of the other words and
making your brain more and more familiar
with with how the language works so
there you have it about noticing i hope
that was useful and this weekend i
promise i will do my video in portuguese
and tonight i'm having dinner with a
brazilian couple so thank you for
listening bye for now